you know initially with v tubing what
made you want to
go for that was it purely just for the
not wanting to put makeup on or was
there something about it that you kind
of were kind of leaning towards with the
whole v-tubing that made you want to go
for it in the first place
i thought um
well i just thought v-tubing was cool
right
look like it's it's gonna
make some movement or something like
that something about say money
i felt like a money
yeah
did you have like anyone any streamers
that kind of inspired you to start
youtubing in the first place um of
course uh kidzuna
yeah she was so inspiring um
did you guys um watch the the backstreet
boys
that movie of kizuna ai chan singing
what what everybody yeah
are you serious that was the one that
got me into youtubing stuff really yeah
wait so what so what is it it was that
wasn't mmd though
yeah i thought so
yeah yeah yeah i didn't know if it was v
tubing or m d but i feel it felt like
the animation it's kind of like a v
tubing so the backstreet boys got you
into youtubing um not like that
that's a good sentence i think
that's like that's like the domino
that's like the domino image right
backstreet boys forms caisson becomes a
v tuber
the whole v tubing industry
[Laughter]
backstreet
yeah yeah
justin timberlake it was like mmd models
though he's not i that sag backstreet is
like that's
so like before you started streaming on
youtube were you mainly on youtube like
watching stuff on youtube or were you on
like nico nico as well on other sites
i didn't know much uh about
youtube because um
i didn't watch it i just i just didn't i
didn't find any
content interesting for me yeah now but
um what's the nikon eco community like
because people people a lot of people
who you know obviously can't speak
japanese and especially the
international audience to me it feels
like it's its own very tight-knit
community with its own culture and
everything like that
for me it was like the only platform i
knew
right
so so like you're just like the
perception of the internet was just like
nico nico for you right yeah
i feel it was like that though because
like i used to be on nico nico as well
when i was in high school and it's like
it like they have their own memes that
just like never leave nico nico so were
you watching nico nico from like high
school
i was watching nico nicole i started
watching when i was in
college
and
[Music]
yeah i think i was in college right i
started because my my dad my parents
never
they never let me play games they were
like um
oh
yeah they like super straight straight
super strict about it they were like
games make you stupid all right
it was kind of apparent
did they let you watch my anime no never
wait wait so what did you do in your
free time as a kid
i was hiding under my bed and reading
dragon ball
the true delinquent
the delinquency started from such a
young age of course
because when they say not to do it you
want to do that of course yeah of course
of course
and now look what i'm doing daddy mommy
i'm playing
i'm playing games and talking about
dragon ball and now i am anime
goes full circle
so you were watching it in college and
then when did you think oh man i kind of
want to join in on this um that's what
when i started working um
one of my colleagues were
like
he talked to me like um how um do you
like games and like he started talking
about games and we became good friends
because i was really interested in games
because i started to make money myself
and i was buying a lot of games that
hell yeah i was i was living by myself
so there was no one to stop me so i was
like buying a lot of games playing it
enjoying it and
my colleague was like um there are like
streamers playing games online you
watch it and i got interested in it and
i started watching it
and then and then he said like um
um i
want to stream like them how about we do
it together
let's do the streaming stuff together
we ended up never doing it together
because um he said it he said he
he i don't know he just disappeared
okay i'll do it myself and i started
making movies it it was like just
just um recording it and just cutting
the end it was something like that it's
not like i mean let's plays yeah the
let's play okay yeah yeah yeah okay all
right
and i started like posting it on nico
nico that was my start it was like 2017.
so you had a job before you were doing
this and you were doing the job while
you were posting this stuff as well yeah
am i allowed to ask what you did before
or
um
i was working
let's keep it a secret okay
so i was on that ground
in a job where colleagues disappeared
the delinquent life has been strong
so how long are you posting let's plays
for then um for
for
like three years oh wow and was that
with like did it ever pick up or was it
like just not that many viewers
throughout the whole time
um it
my first very first video that i posted
on nico nicole
came viral
the very first one what did you do okay
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait so i
need to ask what is viral nikoniko
because nico nico on viral
uh it means um like there's a ranking in
nico nicole you guys know nico nico
rankings yeah yeah yeah yeah like that
was like one let's play ranking and
it was like ranking one to five was mine
oh wow it's basically like like uh i
think it's weekly or monthly something
like that
yeah so basically like at the at the
front page of nico nico usually there's
like a ranking for like the top videos
for this week or the top videos for this
month and then they just have links
that's like their algorithm what was so
special about this video
like i imagine i imagine if it's your
first video it's probably bad it's just
it's so it's like it was just born to be
a stream what made it like go like in
the like blow off
i know um the first very first video
that i posted was me struggling
with japanese but trying to play it in
japanese and the first one i was playing
the game siren you guys know siren oh uh
fatal frame no no
is it no no is it a horror game no it's
a different one right yeah it's a game
yeah
it's it's like fatal frame is it just
you raging at the japanese yeah
i could see why that would do well
actually yeah yeah i can see what that
one there are no
i i think no one did that before so yeah
and you did that for three years
and i just kept growing
i
i wasn't like um
constantly doing that i was like
throwing videos on nico nico and like
do nothing for half a year just
disappear just disappear
yeah
i relate to that that's what i did
that's what i did for the first three
years i just throw the video to nico
nico and
do nothing
throw it some more
so i feel i feel like it's it's pretty
rare on nico nico for there to be like
content creators that constantly produce
because they don't make money right you
don't make money so people just at the
cloud yeah just people just do it
because they want to make some [ __ ] yeah
they're just passionate they're just
passionate in their content [ __ ] bro
could you imagine that's the biggest
crime alive
doing sound for free hell no not in this
economy
honestly like i've seen like sometimes
you see nico nico content that gets like
you know that gets reposted on youtube
and it's absolutely [ __ ] insane some
of the content some of the edits are
just like [ __ ] ridiculous yeah
yeah like seeing some of the like the
mad edits yes like during the peak of
the amv years where you know you thought
there were some like mad talented amv
editors which there are and then out of
nowhere you just get this like mad like
clip that just got posted from niko nuko
and it was just [ __ ] insane what they
were doing compared to what you know
what what you could see on youtube i
mean you know like all the vocaloid
producers used to upload this [ __ ]
i started from there yeah it all started
from there and they just did it not
because they were making money off of it
just because they were like i made this
song check it out yeah
how do you feel do you imagine it
was quite easy when i was i i started in
university and i did it for fun but
that's because the university haven't
got bills to pay right
government the loans are paying your
bills exactly you have to spare time as
well right yeah yeah yeah the actual
time is ours it's fair so when did you
like transfer over to youtube and what
made you transfer over platforms to
youtube in the first place
well the viewers like um
told me that they were like
um
be easy to watch it on youtube then nico
nico
they just told me that so okay then i'll
do it on youtube
and it felt like it was more easier for
me to stream on youtube
because to stream on nico nico it's it's
kind of like complicated you have to
put all those put all those softwares in
your pc and it was so complicated for me
and it felt like it was really easy for
me to do it on youtube so i just went to
youtube but i think it's also because
the nikon ecosystem just hasn't changed
at all everything looks like it's like
on live leak on nikon yeah yeah the
quality is like so you don't want to
know it okay you don't want to know what
that is yeah i don't know i remember i
remember before like i would you know
i'd heard about nico nico as an anime
fan you'd hear about this mythical
website that all the japanese people use
called
and i just you know i remember trying to
watch some videos on it and even just
like watching a video you know with
youtube or basically any like western's
video hosting website all you need to do
is just go on the site search up a video
click on the video and you can watch the
video so i remember clicking on some
nikonika links and uh you have to like
sign up to a special account just to
watch videos or something like that yeah
you if you don't have an account on
nikon you can't watch anything yeah
yeah
and then i i remember i like i couldn't
understand what all this like text
flying across the screen
i was just like what is this this is
ruining my viewing experience it's like
i can't see anything this is blocking
the content
how are you how are people watching this
right now whenever you watch like speed
running summoning salt videos whenever
they're runners from japan yeah nico and
you can just see all the comments yeah
yeah all the things flying across the
screen exactly exactly oh my god i
remember
one time i can't yeah i think it was on
nikonuko where one of the madoka
episodes got streamed on nico nico and i
didn't know i didn't know how to like i
didn't have to figure out how to just
like turn off the comments yeah um so
basically whenever yeah whenever
whenever anyone quoted something big
whenever madoka would say a line you'd
see like a line of comments just like
quoting the episode before she said it
right
so it was literally like you know that
what that movie experience where you're
sitting next to someone who's quoting
the entire vlog
it was just like that but online
basically